♪♪
-You know, you're re-recording.
This is your second re-record.
-Yes.
I feel like -- I know
that everybody has busy lives,
so I -- I do feel the need to,
like, explain what I'm doing
because it's not normal.
-Yeah.
-Basically, like, music --
I've always wanted
to own my own music
since I started making music,
and if --
You probably don't know this,
but most of your favorite
artists do not own their work.
The music industry is, uh --
Eh, you know?
Certain corners of it.
But I think that there was --
There was something that
happened years ago where I --
I made it very clear
that I wanted to be able
to buy my music.
That opportunity
was not given to me,
and it was sold
to somebody else.
And so I just figured, I was the
one who made this music first.
I can just make it again.
-Yeah.
-So that's what we're doing.
[ Cheers and applause ]
-I have to say...
-So that's what we're doing.
So when something says
"(Taylor's Version)"
next to it,
that means I own it,
which is exciting.
[ Cheers and applause ]
-It's -- It's quite -- It's
quite a clever loophole, Taylor.
-Oh, thank you.
-I really tip my cap.
It's -- You know, it's
also interesting to kind of
go back and relive
this nostalgia with fans
who are the reason
why I get to do this
and why I get to, like, sit here
and, like, have
this lovely chat with you.
Going back and -- and reliving
these things with the fans.
And this time around,
I get to really --
I get to do things
that I know they wish
I would have done
the first time.
-That's really good.
-Because I'm always listening
and I'm always lurking.
And I'm always listening
to their opinions
and their theories.
And what --
You know, they'll -- they --
They will let me know which
songs should have been singles.
-Yeah.
-They let me know which songs
did not get videos
and should have gotten videos!
And so I just like --
You know what?
Like, I'm listening
and I'm making the videos
and I'm doing the things.
[ Cheers and applause ]
-That is really cool.
You know, I've got three kids.
They're all really young.
They're under 7,
and I'm trying to
impress my music taste on them.
And I'm wondering,
your kids are older.
Do they like
Bruce Springsteen music?
-Um...
At first, they didn't know
any Bruce Springsteen music
for a very, very, very
long time.
-How do you keep it from them?
-Strangers would come up to us
and I used to always have
this thing I'd tell them.
I'd say, "Look, my job?
I'm Barney for adults, alright?
And that's why people
keep coming up to us."
And then eventually,
one of my children came home
from kindergarten and said,
"Dad, what is
'Tenth Avenue Freeze-Out'?"
And I said, "Well, it's
a song that Dad wrote."
"Play it for me."
I got my guitar,
and I started --
♪ Tenth Avenue... ♪
"Play it for real."
[ Laughter ]
Okay. [ Chuckles ]
And I played him the song
and he got it.
And then totally ignored
that part of my life for
most of the rest of my life,
to this day.
You know, they get
a kick out of it sometimes.
But for the most part...
There was --
I always say, no child
wants to see 50,000 people
cheer their parents.
[ Laughter ]
You may want to see
50,000 people boo your parents.
That would be fun.
That would be interesting.
But who wants to see 50,000
people cheer their parents?
No kid does. No kid.
So we have a very
peaceful coexistence
where they pretend
it never happened.
[ Laughter ]
And, you know,
they picked their own heroes.
They don't need me.
-I have a clip
that I want to ask you about.
-Yes.
-This is from the BET Awards.
And this -- I'm very impressed
with you here
because -- let's be honest --
something goes wrong here
and you have an ability,
to recover that I'm very --
Should we show the clip first?
Yeah, let's just show the clip,
and then we'll talk about it.
-Are you talking
about the BET --
-Yeah.
-Are you gonna do that
to a brother?
-I'm gonna do it to you
right now.
-♪ Being a broke... ♪
-Yeah!
♪ Drinking
more liquor ♪
♪ Drivin'
a broke Vigor ♪
♪ I'm with
Mo' sippers ♪
♪ Watched
by gold... ♪
-[ Laughs ]
You fully --
So, what happened?
What happened?
[ Cheers and applause ]
[ Cheers and applause continue ]
-Hey. You know what
I tell people all the time?
♪ I'm only human ♪
[ Laughter ]
-Right? That's good.
-So, what happened was --
[ Laughter ]
But I'm performing
in front of, like --
-This stuff's great, man,
I tell you.
-You love it, right?
[ Laughter and applause ]
Cîroc Apple --
coming to a place near you.
-Yeah.
-Very soon.
But check this out.
I'm performing
in front of, like,
30 million people live on TV.
I pride myself on being one of
the coolest guys in the world.
I don't make mistakes like this.
-Yeah, yeah, yeah.
-Okay?
-So I walk over the trap door.
Lil' Kim is about to come up.
I get a little excited.
Kendrick Lamar is in the front.
I'm competitive. I run up.
I'm like, "Kendrick, you see me.
You see me rocking."
-Uh-huh. [ Laughs ]
-But I forget about
the trap door behind me
that was closed when
I was going out to the front.
-Right.
-And so, then, when
I turned around, it was open.
-Right.
-Okay?
But let me tell you this --
there's a part you didn't show.
I'm a superhero.
-Okay.
-Okay? I go by the name
of Blackman.
-You just told me
you're only human.
[ Laughter and applause ]
-Sometimes.
-Okay. Gotcha.
-Okay.
-So you're Blackman.
-So I'm Blackman.
I'm falling through the hole.
It feels like it's three hours.
It's only like 2.2 seconds.
-Sure.
-My superpower is I go --
I put my arms out to the side.
I push myself up.
I throw myself up in the air.
I land on beat.
I have this embarrassing
look on my face,
but I'm not facing the camera.
And I say to myself, "You better
get that look off your face,"
and turn around, and I'm like...
[ Laughter ]
[ Cheers and applause ]
-Well, cheers to that,
because I will say...
every man falls down,
but it's about how
you pick yourself back up,
and that was...
-If you fall through a hole...
-Yeah.
-...get up
-Get back up.
-Do you think aliens are real?
-I know that they're real.
-Gotcha.
This isn't a "think" thing.
-No, this isn't a thing --
How --
How self-centered would we be
as humans to believe
that we are the only
living things in the universe?
-Um, well,
call me self-centered,
'cause I don't believe
in aliens.
[ Laughter ]
-Well...
I'm also just, like, a huge fan
of conspiracy theories.
-You love conspiracy theories.
-Yes.
-You -- This is,
I think, my favorite
'cause I heard that you are --
you're all-in on mermaids.
-Okay, I can explain.
-Great.
-Okay.
-I would like you to.
-So, you know Atlantis --
how there was
that underground sea?
-Yeah.
-Okay. Or, no.
-An underground city.
-You know what I mean.
-Sorry. Underwater city.
-Yes.
-Yeah.
-So I believe --
-We're being very convincing.
-I know. I know.
I'm really convincing.
-We're off to a great start.
[ Both laughing ]
-Yeah, right?
No, I believe that there could
possibly be mermaids,
which is a --
actually an alien species
that lives in parts
of the Indian Ocean,
which we have never explored
before as human beings.
-Okay.
-And Columbus --
Christopher Columbus
had actually seen three mermaids
on his way to America.
-Yeah. Alright.
So...
-I just think it's --
it's possible.
And there's this, like, really
extremely convincing documentary
that came out.
-Gotcha.
"The Little Mermaid"?
-Mnh.
[ Laughter ]
[ Cheers and applause ]
[ Both laugh ]
-No! It was on, like,
National Geogra--
No, Discovery Channel.
-Gotcha.
-And then, like, the next day,
they had to say it was fake,
and then it went missing.
-Oh, 'cause they were because
the mermaid lobby was like,
"Hey, you be quiet."
-Yes!
Hey, you know what?
-Look, you can -- this
is the most fun I've had...
-You brought it up.
-...during an interview.
Yeah, I did bring it up.
That's true.
Alright, look,
nothing would make me happier
than mermaids being real.
I'd rather live in your world
than mine, where I'm a cynic
and I just wake up
every morning and be like,
"Well, I'm not going to see
a mermaid."
[ Laughter ]
-It must be really sad, then,
for you to not...
-Yeah.
-...believe that mermaids exist.
-Do you think they look
like the mermaids of books?
-No.
-Okay.
-No. I mean, they're aliens.
[ Laughter ]
[ Laughter and applause ]
-You mentioned your family.
You have a very loving,
supportive family.
You also might have
the world's best godmother.
-Yeah.
-Dolly Parton.
-I'm pretty lucky.
-Yeah.
[ Cheers and applause ]
-Yeah. I'm pretty lucky.
-You guys did a Super Bowl
commercial together.
-Yes.
-You've done album work
together.
-Which, it was amazing because,
you know, she was doing
it for the phones, yet every
time I coordinate and kind of
communicate with Dolly,
it's still through fax.
-You have to --
-So I don't know
what she's talking about.
She's rarely on the phone.
Next time we have to do it for
the fax machine.
-So if you see her
in a commercial talking about
how great phones are, just know
that's some false advertising?
-We do use the phone, but she
does a fax, and then someone
scans the fax, and then they put
it into a text message,
and then that gets sent to me.
-No.
-Yeah.
And it's always signed.
So now I've kind of started
my own version where I go
into the notes, and I've started
to try to make my own letters,
because there's something so
amazing just about a connection.
It's just not casual, you know?
You know that she took the time.
-Yes.
-To get out, I guess
her typewriter?
She also made me a demo one time
where she talks about being
super high-tech, but it was all
through a cassette,
which then she voice memo'd
onto a flip phone,
which someone then
put onto the iPhone,
which then got sent to me.
-I like that she recorded it
on a flip phone,
then she FedEx'd you
the flip phone?
-Yes. She has a phone.
She just doesn't use it,
I don't think.
I think someone uses it for her
and does the fax machine
through the phone.
-I mean, I should make it
very clear that while
we're joking about this,
nothing would make me happier
than if somebody
knocked on my door and said,
"Fax from Dolly Parton."
-Yeah.
-I'd be like --
-From like,
a pink pigeon or something.
A flamingo probably delivers it.
-It's just, like, a pigeon
knocking on the glass
outside the window.
-Yes.
With long acrylic nails,
big boobs, and a blonde wig.
[ Laughter ]
The Dolly Pigeon.
-"I think that's
Dolly's pigeon." Yeah.
-Yeah.
-And now, "Jolene" is a song --
The inspiration for "Jolene,"
if I'm correct,
was a bank teller?
-Well, yeah, it was a girl
that worked at the bank --
I'll tell the real story --
when my husband and I
first got married.
And this beautiful girl
was working at the bank.
She had everything I didn't,
like legs and stuff.
You know, she was tall,
beautiful.
And he was just spending
a lot of time down there.
And I thought, "I know we ain't
got that kind of money."
-Yeah.
-Not right now.
So, he said he was down there,
you know, working on --
trying to get along,
'cause he was in asphalt paving
at that time.
So he was trying to get
a, you know, deal on that,
and I said, "Look, you can talk
to some of these men on that."
-Yeah.
-Or you better get your butt
to the house, or it's going
to be your ass and your wallet.
So finally it was like --
[ Laughter ]
That was kind of the setup
for it.
But "Jolene," of course,
became famous.
-A giant famous song.
And what would you do today
if you ran into another Jolene
with your husband?
-Oh, with my husband?
-Yeah.
-I'd just hide his Viagra.
-Oh, yeah.
[ Laughter ]
Lot easier now. Lot easier now.
-It's a lot easier now!
[ Cheers and applause ]
Actually, though, Jolene was,
you know, quite the girl.
I learned early on, though.
I didn't want to feel jealous,
'cause everybody has
those Jolenes in their life
and are kind of afraid of them.
So I just thought,
well, I'm just going to try
to out-sexy them, you know,
and just try to beat them.
So, I'm 73 years old,
and if you can beat that --
-Yeah, exactly.
[ Cheers and applause ]
[ Both laugh ]
-So, we met
because you played --
You were kind enough
to play at my wedding.
-I was, which --
-You played our first dance.
-I was desperate.
[ Audience "Aws" ]
-It was -- And it was great.
And my wife,
you surprised my wife.
-I did.
-I knew you were coming.
And here's a photo to show
exactly how surprised
my wife was.
There she is. And, uh...
[ Laughter ]
And I was saying this to you
earlier today.
It was heartbreaking 'cause she
had not looked that happy
over the course
of the entire day.
-Yeah. No, she -- Yeah.
-I felt like the whole day,
she was looking at me like,
"Don't blow this."
-Yeah.
-And then you showed up,
and it was, like, "Ahh!"
-It was really weird for me
because I was approached...
I don't know, what was it,
48 hours before this?
-Yeah, you were not given
a ton of time.
-I was like, "This is a prank."
-[ Laughs ]
-But I was a big fan.
I think you're brilliant,
and I thought it would be fun
to go do.
-It was great.
-And I didn't regret it
one minute.
-And you played
this beautiful song
called "She's Everything."
-I did. I did that.
-And now I heard you actually
have director's cuts
of some of your songs...
-Yeah.
-...which are --
you re-write lyrics.
-In the comedy special,
actually. Let me --
Look what we have here.
-There you go.
-One of the things that we --
that I did trying to figure out
what the heck I was gonna
talk about...
♪♪
...was the director's cuts.
You know,
director's cuts in movies,
where they have the clips
that didn't make the film.
-Yeah.
-'Cause "She's Everything"
is a very sweet song.
-It's a perfect, like,
first dance at a wedding song.
-But what if there's lines
that are more realistic?
Especially now that you're
married, you'll understand.
-Okay, got it. So this sort of
the director's cut marriage -
-Right, it's sort of...
-Okay, got it.
♪ She's a yellow pair
of runnin' shoes ♪
♪ A holey pair of jeans ♪
♪ She looks great
in cheap sunglasses ♪
♪ She's a passive-aggressive
little thing ♪
[ Laughter ]
♪ She's almost everything
I ever wanted ♪
♪ Almost everything I need -- ♪
You know what I mean?
-Yeah. [ Laughing ]
-As opposed to, you know...
-Yeah.
[ Cheers and applause ]
You do have this incredible
Christmas song.
We hear it all the time.
Is it your favorite
Christmas song?
-"All I Want for Christmas
Is You"
is this the first
Christmas song I ever wrote.
-Uh-huh.
-And is it my favorite?
I don't --
I love all Christmas songs.
-You love them all?
-I do.
-Come on, there's a couple
of dogs in there.
-I love Christmas --
oh, well, yeah.
-I've recorded some --
-I mean, are you ever happy
when someone starts
"The Twelve Days of Christmas"?
-Depends who it is.
-Oh, that's true.
I guess there are some people.
I guess I wouldn't be bummed
if you started.
I would say, "Oh, my God,
I'm going to get
so much Mariah right now."
-I don't know,
not with "Twelve Days."
-Because you're the expert,
the queen --
my term, not yours --
is it --
when is it too early to start
playing Christmas songs?
-I have a whole thing
about this.
-Okay, good.
-Okay. Because I'm a New Yorker.
-Yeah.
-We love New York,
and it's a great place to be
at Christmas.
Um.
Although I go to Aspen
because I'm guaranteed snow.
-Okay, gotcha.
-So I have to have that.
-You need to have snow?
-It's kind of
a big deal to me, yes.
-Okay. Gotcha.
-Santa Claus comes.
There's a real sleigh
with real reindeer.
-Right, 'cause here in New York,
he has to take the subway.
[ Laughter ]
-Yeah, I mean, like, in Aspen,
he just knows the way
to my house.
-Okay. There you go.
-Yeah.
-Is Christmas a huge deal
in Mariah Carey's household?
-Of course.
-You take it super seriously?
-I do.
But, I mean, we have fun.
Like, we go on a sleigh ride.
-That's good.
-Lots of things.
-Yes.
I mean,
we're here in our mock...
-Mock sleigh ride. Please.
-You could have
come to my sleigh ride,
and I would have --
you would have been really --
-Next time, we'll do a live
remote from your sleigh ride.
-Yes. And we can do it,
like, kind of like --
even like a bathtub sleigh ride.
Like, we'll have clothing.
-Okay.
-Although, you know, it'll
just be, like, more relaxing.
-Oh, my goodness.
-'Cause that's part of it.
-I'm so in on this --
every part of this.
[ Laughter ]
A bathtub sleigh ride.
-Bathtub sleigh ride.
-Sign me up.
-With diamonds and everything.
-Didn't know it was a thing.
-It's a thing.
Now can't stop thinking
about it.
-Well, now
we've made it a thing.
-Now we made it a thing.
-We made it a thing.
-"Honey, I have Christmas plans
for next year."
"Where are you going?"
-Yes.
"Aspen, with Mariah Carey,
in a bathtub with diamonds."
-Soaking in the sleigh.
-I want to see
if you'll confirm or deny this,
'cause Vin Diesel
was on a talk show --
he was on "Jimmy Kimmel"
last week.
-Ohh, no, no, no, no, no.
-And he said he --
he said he was a backup dancer
for the Beastie Boys --
or a dancer
for the Beastie Boys,
not even a back-up --
I didn't even know
you guys had dancers.
-Look I didn't want to
talk about this,
but my best friend,
Nadia Dajani, said I have to.
-Yes.
-And Nadia and Seth are friends.
And so she texted Seth
and was like,
"You got to talk to him
about it."
I don't want to start
a whole thing,
but I did see on the Internets
Vin Diesel,
one of my favorite actors...
If you haven't seen
the movie "XXX,"
I suggest you get high or drunk
and watch it
'cause it's [bleep] funny
as [bleep]
[ Laughter ]
...claimed on
Jimmy Kimmel's show last week
that he was a breakdancer
for Beastie Boys,
and he was not.
-This is not true?
-No, he Vanilla Ice'd.
-There's no way?
-He straight Vanilla Ice'd.
-Wow.
-I know.
-Where was the name?
Where did he say he was?
-Danceteria? Where was --
-At Danceteria.
-Okay.
-No, no, no, no.
So what -- So what I think --
What my wife Kathleen
was saying
was that perhaps we were
going into Danceteria --
this is a club
we used to go to all the time
when we were kids --
and that one of us -- probably
Yauch 'cause he's a nice guy --
saw all this kid
and was like,
"You know, just --
we'll say you're a breakdancer.
You know, you're with our band,
and blah, blah, blah."
So that could have happened.
But that's not the way
that Mark Vincent told it --
or Vin Diesel, you know?
-Mm-hmm. Mm-hmm.
-And so he was --
he said he was a breakdancer
for the Beastie Boys.
That's weird, you guys.
-Well, look.
[ Laughter ]
-I think if I'm --
-No?
-It's a -- I'm looking --
I think it has an early jump
on the best feud of the year --
you and Vin Diesel.
I'm really hoping --
-He's big and muscle-y, though.
-Yeah, he is.
-What happens?
-That's why I can't believe
you're not out here saying,
"Yeah, he was our breakdancer.
He was great."
-He said that we saw him
on a street breakdancing
and were like, "Come on!"
[ Laughter ]
-Had that -- Did that
ever happen with anyone?
Did you ever see a breakdancer
and you went, "Come on!"?
-I've never seen anybody on the
street I didn't know and said,
"Come on!"
[ Laughter ]
That never happened.
-That's another New York PSA --
don't see people
on the street --
-Don't say, "Come on!"
-Never.
-Don't do that.
-Other towns, you can do that.
-I don't know.
-Not New York City.
I wouldn't do it, but that's me.
-I want to do something
real quick here before we go.
-You know, I have done that,
actually, but not here.
I guess you're right.
-You have
brought people with you?
-Do you edit this show, or is it
just all -- this is all in?
-No, we're keeping all of this.
-Okay, good.
[ Laughter ]
Good.
-I imagine you make songs,
and they go out in the world,
and it must be special
when you hear them places
you're not expecting
to hear them.
Maybe you hear it on the radio,
maybe you hear it
in a restaurant,
but you -- you heard that one
of your songs, you were told,
had been used in a --
in a pornographic film.
-Yes.
[ Laughter ]
-And they did not get
your permission for this?
-No. I signed a --
The publishing deal I signed
was...not good, you know,
so I guess there was a loophole
in the contract or something,
and they were able to do this
without asking me first.
-Did you at least feel
that they had, um...
used the spirit of the song
correctly?
[ Laughter ]
-That's a loaded question.
-Wow.
-Well, now, what was the title?
What was the title of the song?
-They probably did use
the song correctly
'cause it was called
"Just Another One Night Stand."
-All right. Well...
-Yeah.
-Yeah, they tend not --
Those films don't tend to have
the longer relationship.
-It involved -- It involved a...
young woman wearing
a cowboy hat and cowboy boots,
a gas station,
and a couple of cowboys.
-Yeah.
-And a pickup truck.
-[ Laughs ]
-That's all we're going to say.
We don't need to keep
talking about it.
-If you've seen
one of them ever,
you can probably finish it.
-Pretty much. Yes.
Well, I'll tell you
the name of it.
-The name of the movie?
-Yes.
-Okay.
-It was called...
[ Laughter ]
You're making me laugh.
It was called
"All-American Girls in Heat."
-Oh.
-"Part Two."
-"Part Two"?
-"Part Two." Yeah.
-Well, that's good.
I mean, and do you think --
Do you think, for people
that are looking it up,
they should see the first one?
Do you think
they'll be able to follow
the plot of the second one
if they haven't...?
-Yeah, I think they'll be able
to pick up
right where
the other one left off.
-So, you worked
with Adam before.
You also worked with Fred.
-Oh.
-And -- Okay.
But this is a true --
Fred used to open for Wilco
doing stand-up.
-Yeah, I didn't know
he was gonna be here.
-Oh, okay.
Was it a weird vibe
back in the day?
-He owes my wife a lot of money.
-Oh, yeah.
So this is a --
You --
[ Laughter ]
This is true that Fred
made a promise to your wife.
-He made a legal document.
-Okay.
-Several times, we -- Yeah.
-And, now, what was the impetus
of Fred making this --
-My wife gave him his start
in show business
by allowing him
to answer the phones
at the rock club that she owned.
-Okay. This is true, Fred?
-Sure.
-Okay, and so in return,
what did Fred promise your wife?
-Initially, he promised 50%
of all of his earnings.
-Okay.
[ Laughter ]
-And then when she
confronted him about it...
-Sure, as you would
if he didn't pay up.
-...he said he was sorry
and he would give her 75%.
-Got it.
And, now, you've actually
brought the legal document?
-I do have the document with me.
-Now, it is a video document.
-Yes.
-And, Fred, you will confirm
that you made this?
-Yes.
-Okay. Here is Fred.
And hopefully, if anybody here,
you know, passed the bar --
-I have my lawyer with me.
-Okay, great. Alright.
Let's see if you believe
this is a legal document.
-This is a legal document
without jokes,
without irony or sarcasm.
This is not an exaggeration.
I, from now on,
owe Susan Miller
75% of my income.
It used to be 50%.
It's up to 75%
because retroactively
going back to the amount
I owe her before,
I need to add to that.
That is all monies brought in by
any comedy or any entertainment.
That is what's owed.
If you are a lawyer
looking at this,
there is no irony in my face
or, like, any winking.
I owe this money.
By the way, immediately.
[ Laughter ]
-I mean, I think
that's a legal document.
[ Cheers and applause ]
-I -- Slam dunk.
-But Fred's
a little shady, though.
That's the problem.
Is it true that when Fred --
-How much could it be?
-10 grand?
-Something in there, yeah.
-Yeah.
-You've made probably around
12 to 15 grand.
-I would say 12 to 15.
-Yeah.
So then you're getting
75% of that.
You're gonna do pretty well.
You did something on the show
that I get --
I will be honest -- you --
you -- you threw your shoe.
This is a photo of you.
Someone was singing.
They finished their song.
I believe it was
"Try a Little Tenderness."
Was that the song?
-Yes.
-Which is --
was incredibly well sung.
And then you threw your shoe,
which -- I will be honest --
if I was onstage
and a shoe came up...
[ Laughter ]
...I'd think that was
an unsatisfied customer.
-No!
-Okay, interesting.
-It is a compliment.
-Well, at J-Hud Productions,
it's a compliment.
-Gotcha.
-Come on, now.
[ Cheers and applause ]
If you move me enough
that I remove my shoe
to throw it at you,
you have done something
just amazing.
-That's fanta--
-Like, it's equivalent
to a standing ovation.
-Interesting.
-Yeah.
-Has this been your --
Has anyone
ever thrown a shoe at you?
-Oh, yes.
-Okay.
-I did -- I had an audition
for a tour with Barry Manilow,
like, I don't know
how many years ago that was.
And I sang a song.
And the people who
I was auditioning in front of --
they literally threw everything
at me off of the desk.
-Wow!
[ Light laughter ]
-And I was just standing there
like, "Oh, my God."
It was shoes. It was notebooks.
It was pens and everything.
They was like,
"Girl, you better sing!"
[ Laughter ]
-That's great.
-So when somebody's singing
for me...
-You get -- yeah.
-...you might catch a shoe.
And if I could get this boot off
right now...
-Yeah, well, that's --
[ Laughter ]
Now, this is interesting,
because was noticing your boots
as you came in.
It would seem -- Now, do you
ever think before a night,
"Hey, I might see something
I really like.
I should wear shoes
that are easy to get off"?
[ Laughter and applause ]
[ Cheers and applause ]
I mean, I'll say this.
If I -- If I -- the next time
I go to see you live,
I'm just gonna wear Crocs,
'cause I want to get them --
get them off.
[ Laughter ]
They're soft.
If I should accidentally hit you
in the head, you'll be fine.
-Maybe I should carry one
in my purse.
-[ Laughing ] Yeah, exactly.
Well, that would be great.
A purse shoe --
that's what you need.
[ Laughter ]
-A purse shoe.
-And then people will say,
"Did Jennifer like you?"
And they'll say,
"Well, she threw a shoe,
but it was in her purse."
-"She threw a shoe."
Right, right.
-Yeah.
You always have
great judges on the show.
And then you have had --
Rihanna has come on
as a consultant, I guess.
What do you call Rihanna?
-Wait a minute.
Because I got to...
They came to me before the show,
and they're like,
"Man, Seth really wants to talk
to you about Rihanna.
He's like obsessed
with Rihanna."
-I kind of am, yeah.
-Okay.
-I want to know everything.
-So I was like,
"Okay, what are we gonna" --
So let's hear it.
-Yeah. Well, let's hear it.
No, you're the one
who got to hang out with her.
You tell me.
Is it awesome?
-Yes.
-Yeah.
-She was like --
She was asking about you.
-No, I don't believe that.
-She was.
-Why would she?
Why would somebody
on "The Voice" ask about me?
That doesn't make sense.
-I don't know.
[ Laughter ]
She's really cool.
I actually was --
I was nervous about that, too,
because it's like,
it's one thing
when we ask a mentor to help,
but then, the last few seasons,
they've had this mega mentor
that comes in,
and it's been like Taylor Swift
and, you know, other people.
-Right.
-And then -- And then...
I can't remember.
-Yeah, they really made
an impact on you.
-Because it's like Taylor Swift
and Rihanna are the two
that stand out in my mind.
-Yeah, they are.
-But she's so like --
She's such a smartass, man.
-She's really -- Yeah.
-I'm like, "Oh, my God,
I'm totally going to push
this girl around,
you know, with my crazy wit."
-Yeah. [ Laughs ]
-And I never could get
the upper hand with her.
She's totally...
The only thing I could
embarrass her about a little bit
was because I was trying
to get her to be,
like, flirty a little bit,
you know?
I mean, why not?
-Right. Yeah.
-I mean, I'm a perfect match
for Rihanna.
-Yeah.
[ Laughter ]
-And so, I was coming up
with our, like --
our couple name, and...
-Oh, right.
-...Blihanna was one of them.
-Blihanna. That's good.
-And I tried Rake. And that --
-That doesn't work.
Yeah, Blihanna --
-Actually, neither one of them.
-They're not great, but of
the two, Blihanna's better.
It's interesting you say
flirting with her,
because she's one of
those people that,
because she did "SNL"
and she did music a bunch of
times when I was there,
and I remember once
walking by in the hallway,
and she was like,
"Hey, how's it going?"
And I think I said like
[Babbles indistinctly]
[ Laughter ]
So, I think if she was
asking about me,
she might have been saying,
"Is he brain damaged?"
-[ Speaking indistinctly ]
You never get over the stroke.
-Yeah.
♪♪